question is what is the number one  problem facing men today and what is the  number one problem facing women today  I'm gonna say something come on guys  the number one problem answer all the  questions come on the number one problem  with men is that they don't tell women  the truth and a number one problem with  women that get caught they can't handle  the truth simple oh that's a good that's  a good Paradigm to start from because  it's actually very interesting you say  that a lot of women say I just want a  man who's honest and then the second  you're honest she's like what you did it  wrong it's like well then don't ask me  for honesty of course I [ __ ] lie  thank you so that's a good that's a good  point I agree with that one